How does one distinguish a statement coming from oneself rather than from
radiology?
Hey,
I got a good hint about that.
If you're saying something that almost anyone else could say,
then it's likely to be either cliched or ideological.
Where is,
if you're speaking from yourself,
then in some sense you're the only person who could be saying that.
And so what that means in some sense is that you've taken ideas,
philosophical,
even ideological,
and you've made them personal so that you're speaking from a position that only
you can speak from.
And then then you have something original offer.
Um,
in Solzhenitsyn school,
like archipelago,
he talked about,
uh,
like radical communists who were thrown into the Gulag and they used to play
comrade with them.
It was a game.
And what they would do is bait them into making continual propagandistic
communists statements.
It was an attempt to try to educate them out of their possession.
But it's a good,
see if you can predict what someone is going to say on the basis of their set of
beliefs,
then they're not speaking.
The ideology is speaking.
And if the ideology is speaking,
you don't even have to listen to them.
You could just read about the ideology and make up your own mind now.
So that's,
that's sort of the,
uh,
what would you call it?
That's the objective view of this.
The subjective view is that statements come from yourself that come from
yourself.
I think first of all,
frighten you to some degree because you actually opened yourself up to the world
by saying something genuine,
but they also make you stronger.
They make you feel stronger put because I think you're confronting your
vulnerability properly.
You know?
Because if I tell you something that I really don't believe and you criticize,
it's like who cares?
Because I don't really believe but believe it anyways,
so maybe I have an ideology that's like a mask or a persona,
which is generally the case personas,
a end concept that means mask.
And it's often the thing that people confuse with their real identity.
Well,
if I have a persona and someone criticizes it,
it's like,
well,
you haven't got to the real meat.
But if I say something that I really believe deeply believe,
and then it gets criticized,
like I've really put myself on the line.
And so people don't do that.
It's kind of frightening,
but it's,
it's still the way to genuine strength because you need,
and also not just strength,
but also value.
You need to manifest yourself in the world because you're a unique thing and
people bite need.
What's unique about you?
Everybody else might really need that.
I believe that you don't because each person has something that's unique to them
to bring into being.
And if they hide that,
they hide their light under a Bushel,
that everyone is poorer for it.
And you do that in part as Social Nitsa says,
by turning in,
you're turning over your God given sole to human dogma.
It's a very bad idea.
Very bad idea.